[Musique]
karine vanasse bonjour bonjour à tous
bonjour aux auditeurs et aux auditrices
alors vous êtes candidate sur la 2e
circonscription celle du nord vous est
présentée par la france soumise voilà
alors qu'est ce qui motive aujourd'hui
votre candidature
bah écoutez je suis je suis une femme
engagée mobilisés depuis toujours je
suis sur le terrain je suis avec les
associations dans les différentes luttes
les différentes causes depuis depuis un
certain temps maintenant je vais pas
vous dire quand puisque vous allez de
vider mon âge
mais
voilà et je le suis pour la martinique
depuis un bon moment je suis aussi le
meilleur je suis inquiète pour l'avenir
des petits martiniquais est inquiète
pour mes enfants et je pense que
voilà il fallait que je prenne ma part
et que
j'allais au charbon pour essayer de
régler ou en tout cas d'apporter ma
pierre à l'édifice d'accord il n'y a pas
d'autres candidatures comme à dire
unique qu'il n'y a pas de baisse
martine martinez qu'il ya des
candidatures différencier c'est ça en
martinique comme dans les autres outre
mer le l'accord du ps n'a pas été enfin
ne s'étend pas à nous donc en fait les
candidats sont investis par leur parti
ou leur mouvement ce qui est le cas de
trois personnes en martinique qui sont
investis par la france soumise en france
a sonné c'était ça alors concernant la
circonscription dans de laquelle vous
présentez quelles seraient les trois les
deux trois grandes priorités que vous
comptez portée c'est compliqué de
hiérarchiser les difficultés les
problèmes qui pèsent sur les épaules des
martiniquais c'est c'est compliqué mais
bon s'il faut choisir trois points je
dirais que je m'attaquerai
très rapidement au problème de la vie
chère et à redonner du pouvoir d'achat
aux martiniquais par exemple avec le
larves et la revalorisation du smic à
1500 euros
le blocage la baisse et le blocage des
prix de produits des produits de
première nécessité du carburant etc
je pense aussi qu'il est temps de
s'attaquer pardon aux facteurs qui qui
perpétue l' isolement le l'enclavement
du nord
bon il ya des solutions il faut qu'on
les apportent par exemple réorganiser
les services publics au niveau du
transport etc et puis dernier point
serait qu'on mette une fois pour toutes
un terme à
tous les questionnements concernant le
dossier du chlordécone et qu'on apporte
des solutions à la population et en
termes de des empoisonnements décorant
de du tsol de nos mères etc mais aussi
en termes de soins
d'indemnisation voilà et tout ça bon
sinon au delà de ça et en parallèle de
ces points programmatiques
j'espère aussi participer au
renouvellement de la classe politique
martiniquaise qui est sclérosé depuis
des années et où les les les volontés
les compétences les intelligences ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer et puis et puis
essayer de toutes mes forces de redonner
aux martiniquais ou martin cas du nord
singulièrement un peu d'espoir un peu de
respiration et que les gens puissent
vivre dignement est-ce que vous pensez
que le résultat du premier tour de la
présidentielle va faire que vous serez
plus audible aujourd'hui convainc plus
vous entendrez mieux vous entendrez à la
limite mieux vous comprendre oui je
pense
les martiniquais se sont exprimés mais
au-delà de ça il ya quelque chose qui
nous est apparu sur le terrain c'est que
les gens se sont emparés de la de la
chose politique les gens nous parlait du
programme les gens nous disaient ah vous
vous proposez telle chose et c'est ouais
c'est bien
ce qui veut bien dire qu'ils sont allés
chercher qui sont à l'écouté qui l'ont
lu qu'ils ont lu et écouté donc je pense
que les les martiniquais mais bon encore
une fois les personnes dans le nord les
martiniquais de ma circonscription
sont aujourd'hui avertis et savent
aujourd'hui que s'ils votent pour moi il
vote pour un programme ils votent pour
envoyer des députés à l'assemblée
nationale pour faire barrage à macron
pour faire barrage aux politiques de
macro et et ils savent aussi ce qu'on
propose donc voilà je fais confiance
vous avez de france est un peu ma
première et ma dernière question c'était
qu'avez vous à dire aux électeurs mais
j'ai envie de vous n'avez pas parlé de
la santé ah oui parce que
c'est le vaste comme je vous dis il ya
tellement de dossiers
des heures milieu médical oui mais la
bague à la mauvaise tellement il fallait
choisir mais c'est vrai il faut mettre
un terme aussi à
ou en tout cas apporter des solutions au
problème de l'accès aux soins de l'accès
aux soins des déserts médicaux du manque
de médecins des difficultés qu'ont les
gens d'al à aller vers vers les médecins
vers les spécialistes etc oui
effectivement il ya un gros travail à
faire à ce niveau madame à navarra
chevreau merci
[Musique]